in Maniac you play a serial killer Yes I
think you were born to play a serial
killer you're a terrific actor but I
think you really do I think you have
this I could see you just having a very
good evil Persona do you know what I'm
saying yeah I just think you have that
look at you can you can look at that
look at the eyes you can see it in the
eyes
[Applause]
stick
ER
[Applause]
that's fantastic
you uh have you thought about because
you seem like such a sweet person in
real life have you thought about were
you a serial killer I mean playing this
role how would you kill
um
seriously who hasn't thought about that
I think about this all the time
I've never really thought about how I
would kill but I've thought about I've
been in those scenarios this happens a
lot actually where I'll be just falling
asleep and I'll think I'll run through
an entire scenario of a home invasion
so someone's in my house and how am I
going to deal with this and I don't have
any kind of weapon in my house I don't
have a bat under my bed or a gun or
anything like that so I guess I would
probably grab like the the extender for
a vacuum cleaner because that's like the
only thing that is like a a long enough
weapon but it's kind of wimpy but
whatever it wouldn't really hurt
something it wouldn't hurt them but it
would potentially disarm them so if they
came in with a knife or a gun right
smack it out of their hand
and then I think I would try and reach
for the gun and and just you know I
would maim the person I wouldn't want to
kill them this is a terrible plan maybe
it might be the worst plan I've ever
heard now I'll use this long thin tube
to get the gun out of their hand and
then reach for it and then aim for a
non-lethal area
can you take out a knee and then get on
the phone and you know yeah and then
like vacuum them and mock them
yeah
you want to make sure I get to this uh
Elizabeth Wilfred Wilfred now in third
in in its third season such a creative
show such a funny show uh and we have a
clip here from Wilfred but uh you know
you hear about the idea that this is a
guy and his his dog yes and his dog is
played by a grown actor in a dog suit
it's very funny yes uh so I'm just
curious uh well can you tell us
something about this clip because we
have a very secret clip of Wilfred uh
showing Ryan my character
um a website for stuffed animals but
he's reading it like a like it's a sex
site like a sex dating site okay your
dog showing you yes
yeah very nice very clear look at this
clip from Milford
Ryan check out this internet site I
found it's for people who just want to
have raunchy demented sex no strings
attached
stuffed animal story.com look at the
expression on that face I bet
you've been seeing trunk
oh dude check the horn on that freak
I'm with you today I thought you and
bear were married we were but married
life's not really for me it's just such
a